as you said earlier like the whole
accountability thing I'm not saying that
men don't play a part in the way that a
woman feels but we do have to be
accountable and responsible for our own
emotions and for our own decisions that
we make you know as someone else in the
Super Chat mentioned about uh it just
went from my mind now but about women
not understanding men and I can kind of
appreciate that to some degree I like to
think I do understand men to a certain
degree but that's only men that I've
engaged with the men that I've come
across we operate from a completely
different mental and we're very
different as human beings and I said it
last time you know men and women do
complement each other we're not the same
and I think that there's a lot of
responding and not enough listening yeah